welcome to thick boy fighters let's dive
in boxing superstar tyson fury is going
viral after a video made the rounds of
the two-time heavyweight champion making
remarks about immigration the video
posted by journalist karim zidon on
twitter shows fury saying the uk needs
to worry about its own suffering people
before taking on more immigrants that
need care the video has divided fans of
fury with some agreeing with his stance
and others objecting to it
let's face it
we're in thousands and thousands of
immigrants here
um daily
that's not even from here burn here
but we've got our own people dying on
the streets homeless
who can't get anything you can't get no
money you can't get help
you know what's going on
what's going on great britain
fall in the name great
britain come on
it's not so great is it when we're uh
letting our fellow brothers and sisters
die on the streets he's been born and
bred here but then we have 50 000
immigrants in from wherever they're from
crying poverty
and then they're gonna blow blows up
so
it is what it is
we're pretty [ __ ] up at the moment and
i i'm bigger and brave enough to say how
he is
in unfortunate news flyweight muay thai
champion rod tang jitwan on has
withdrawn from his grand prix semi-final
bout this weekend raw tang did not
provide his mandatory hydration sample
on thursday and was not permitted to
weigh in one championship has some of
the most progressive weigh-in policies
to ensure fighter health is a top
priority friday night's 1 on prime video
1 will still feature the highly
anticipated flyweight world championship
rematch between adriano marias and
demetrius johnson the pair last fought
in april 2021 where marias knocked out
johnson with a knee in the second round
at the official press conference for the
event johnson was asked if he would be
taking a different approach fighting
marias for a second time
my style never changes my styles always
come forward and in mixed martial arts
you know the way i was brought up in
this sport is supposed to be a clash
right a struggle just like in wrestling
you know there's always a struggle
between two human beings so for me go
out there and push the pace and just
fight
mariah's told reporters that while he
doesn't feel like he has anything left
to prove he is fully prepared to defend
his title
what's up uh i don't think i have enough
to prove uh of course yeah i'm a mma
fighter i like to challenge myself
and as a champion i just go there and
defend my belt whatever they're gonna
point out for me i need to be ready to
defend my throne and i will be thank you
thank you
marias also told reporters that he feels
like another victory over johnson would
make him the goat of the flyweight
division steven wonderboy thompson has
turned down a fight with up-and-coming
welterweight shavkat rakhmanov thompson
who was coming off back to back losses
to grapplers gilbert burns and bellam
muhammad told bjpenned.com he turned on
the fight because he wants to fight
another striker the ufc was talking
about maybe shafka he just beat neil
magni i was like look ufc give me
someone that is going to want to strike
with me i haven't turned down the last
two guys who are grapplers one of the
top grapplers in the welterweight
division didn't turn him down i was like
give me a striker it doesn't make sense
for me to face another heavy grappler
let me work on my craft a little more
especially when it comes to wrestling
they were pushing it but it just doesn't
make sense the fans didn't want to see
it either they're like dude give steven
a striker someone who's going to strike
with him it is what it is that is not a
fight that interests me at this point
rafael dossanos tweeted that he is
looking for new motivation as he is at
the tail end of his ufc career rda
believes that his run as a title
contender is over and is looking for
exciting fights with other veterans of
the game i had my last title run and now
is the time to fight people that
motivates me to wake up and train i have
almost eight hours of octagon time get
me a veteran for a change i would love
to fight guys like jim miller jorge
mazvidov or get my rematch with tony
ferguson or guida darren till spoke with
espn's brett akamoto about his plans to
return to the octagon till was scheduled
to fight jack hermansen on july's london
fight night card but had to withdraw due
to an injury till told akamoto that he
is currently helping hamza chimayo train
for his fight with nate diaz we're a few
weeks into getting back homs fully
encamped now for this fight with nate
diaz so i'm like in camp helping him but
i'm in camp for myself to come back the
body's never 100
but i'm coming back what i used to be
like healthy and fit and ready to get a
world title get some wins in massive
fight against one of the best strikers
in the division so this is all just
about getting back now till also gave a
possible timeline for his return i'd say
in a few months time i'll be ready i
want to have two fights by the end of
this year two fights and then next
year's a big year the comeback is on
that wraps up another week of thick boy
fight news head into the weekend with
some friday funnies
that looks like jake paul
gotcha
what i got for 200.
mike that's that's um
the carpenter clay guido
[Music]
this is our close game right here
celebrity crush brian reynolds uh what's
his name tom hardy francis and garner
[Applause]
looking for more original mma content
check out the rest of thick boy youtube
exclusive interviews opinion and fight
analysis is available weekly on the shob
show food truck diaries and fight night
flashbacks subscribe so you don't miss
any of the action
you